[Music]
let's grow thanks elbow boy I guess I'm
just no good at building ramps sorry
what's wrong Zoe oh my ramp doesn't work
I'm just gonna go play with Elmo's whale
oh hold on a second any great
engineering project is gonna involve
some trial and error it's not that your
ramp doesn't work it's just that it
doesn't work yet that's the power of yet
the power kind of Elmo it's a super
power that we all have it's the idea
that mistakes aren't bad and that we
learn from them so we keep trying oh but
I tried my ramp twice already
well what did you try differently the
second time nothing well why don't we
look closer and see if we can try a
different approach
and even if that doesn't work it's okay
we'll learn from it okay well the Zoe
'mobile crashed right here yeah so maybe
I need to just fill this hole oh I think
I have a block that'll do just the trick
oh wait there you go Zoe I like the way
you're thinking like the great engineer
that you are ah all right here let me
try okay come here Zoe mobile here we go
Oh No
oh that's it I'm just getting up no no
no no no not if you believe in the power
of yet you know how your your muscles
get stronger when you exercise oh yeah
I'm super strong what's the
exactly making mistakes and coming up
with solutions to solve your problems is
exercise for your brain when you believe
you can do it and you keep trying that's
what your brain is growing and you are
learning new things it's called a growth
mindset okay well then I'm gonna try
again sorry that time the Zoe 'mobile
crashed right here right so baby if I
get rid of this block Hey look at that
nice straight line all the way down
that'll do it
here let me try okay come here Zoe
'mobile here we can join Elmo's back
total it faster too
let's do it together great job guys I'm
so proud that you kept trying and you
weren't afraid to make mistakes
and because of it we all learned a ton
and that's the power of yet maybe this
does that something here